and let's get a look now at some of the
latest developments in the coronavirus
pandemic
india has recorded another record number
of new infections with almost 70
000 new cases reported on thursday the
country has now ramped up testing to
more than 900
000 people a day italy has also posted
its highest new case load since may
when the country emerged from one of the
longest lockdowns in the world
authorities there reported 642 new
infections on wednesday
and south korea has warned a recent
outbreak from a church in the capital
seoul could spread nationwide
the government has warned that it may
impose the highest level of restrictions
if the numbers continue to rise
well the number of coronavirus cases is
on the rise in germany
as well with authorities recording just
over 1700 new infections in the past 24
hours
it's the highest daily figure since
april when the pandemic was considered
to be at its peak
the surge has been blamed on holiday
makers returning home
as well as parties and family gatherings
earlier this month germany introduced
free mandatory tests for anyone
returning from areas deemed
to be high risk for covid19 infections
let's get more from our correspondent
nina hasa who is standing by
in berlin nina the highest number of
infections
since late april is this the second wave
scientists are cautioning against using
that term they prefer to use the term
a continuous infection wave that will
see natural
ups and downs and they are expecting the
numbers to go up even further come
autumn when people will spend more time
indoors when it's easier for the virus
to spread
having said that of course um there is a
current spike that cannot be denied
and the health minister in spain has
also warned people against
letting their guard down he said lots of
the new clusters that we're seeing
of new infections stem from social
gatherings like family parties or
outdoor rave parties in parks
so given that um
can we expect new restrictions again
there is currently a talk when you speak
about national
restrictions about actually
making masks mandatory also in offices
not just
in on public transport and in
supermarkets
and this is something that they are
considering
but they are cautioning against
imposing wide-arranging national
restrictions again they do
want to keep the economy going they say
that is important also to keep hospitals
running
and of course i think what's important
to remember is that the situation
is quite different to spring we did see
a similar number in spring but two major
things were different one of course
testing has been ramped up massively you
mentioned the mandatory test for people
returning from high-risk areas
and then the majority of new cases is
now with young people they tend to be
more resilient
so authorities are a bit more relaxed
because the strain on hospitals doesn't
seem to be
quite as severe as it was in spring
two's nina hasa in berlin thank you nina
you